During the presidential campaign, Donald
Trump called NATO obsolete. In May, he
imposed a tariff on European steel and
aluminum, ostensibly on national
security grounds. At the same time, his
administration, like all the previous
ones since the end of the Second World
War, remains committed to the defense of
Europe. US military deployments in
Eastern Europe have increased in size
since Trump's inauguration, and perhaps
surprisingly, US sanctions against Russia
have been stronger than those adopted by
the European Union. As the president is
headed to the NATO summit in Brussels on
the 11th and 12th of July, the question
is how those two faces of his
administration can be reconciled. There
are real and legitimate issues at stake.
A free prosperous and secure Europe is
very much in America's interest, but
the United States cannot care about
European security more than Europeans do.
For a long time, US presidents have tried to
persuade the Europeans to invest more
into their defense... without success. Maybe
Donald Trump's bluster and abrasive manners
will bring results where diplomacy has
failed... but don't hold your breath.
What do you think about the role America
has been playing in NATO? Let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe to more research and
videos from AEI.